spider-man spider-man this is a pretty
adequate spider-man yeah that's a review
by okay so we uh we just got back from a
con but we saw a spider-man homecoming
and here anywhere it's a it's raining
outside so sorry there's a thunderstorm
it's a pretentious like prophecy of
things to come yeah maybe
so yeah everyone's loved in this movie
and we liked it too I thought this is a
very fun enjoyable funny ridiculously
charming action movie and as spider-man
movies go it's okay good it's a good
movie I reck goes this yet this will
Teflon this spelled rumor then I think
we're on the Marvel take yeah no okay
okay let's do this because before we get
fucking stone yeah by the internet let's
go over the things we really liked about
the movie first yeah no and I see it's
hard well here's the fine thing to talk
about the best parts to this movie
you kinda have to go and display me so I
can I say what will get just sort of our
initial thought and then we'll do a
burger sporttv I see it as L dunno it
looks after work because really the best
stuff in this film does involve the
spoilers so best thing about it Michael
fucking Keaton I mean Michael is
literally fuckin Keaton no it just it's
just so much you know here's the thing
um what's bothered me about the other
spider-man films is outside of Doc Ock
who I thought I was like that was pretty
close to perfect and this the Sandman
was pretty good but the movie around him
was so terrible you can motivation I
mean it's not the end ins like what
happens to him yeah
and he's the one who was there when like
a Ben was shot yeah is so Green Goblin
kind of goes without saying yeah I both
have a soft spot for him but he's you
know Willem Dafoe himself is amazing
yeah that's the fucking stupid mask and
that glider thing and I never believed
it for one second so this is the first
spider-man villain outside of da cockpit
I'm just like that's it and they managed
to make it different and yeah it's
updated it's brilliant the way they make
it fit within the larger Marvel
Cinematic Universe
he's like scavenging parts left over
from the Avengers battle so all the
alien tech or agent shield tech and
stuff he like scavenges it and builds
his own set of wings
the mask is it's legitimately creepy and
intimidating and his the a very simple
but effective yeah the effects on him
have wait like that was one of the
problems with the Goblin it's a problem
with CGI in general is that when they
fly I feel no sense of weight it's just
like this guy went like he lands and we
need hovers over you I feel like there's
this presence they are looming over you
that I never got with more than the CGI
on spider-man actually the effects all
kind of say are not very good in this
movie is kind of a weird movie but I
mean I'm on yeah we are really not that
much farther than we were like what the
first spider is obviously probably for
effect I'd still say the Marc Webb films
might have the better of Fame yeah
honestly second one gets a little silly
but the the there will be effects on
vulture I thought overall were yeah they
were good solid my his character arc
he actually had a character arc I'm not
entirely sure spider-man's had a
character arc yet but you know where he
came from his motive got invited I know
the vulture oh yeah made sense to me
like I'm like okay I get I get his
motivation I get where he's coming from
the the intro scene was like a little
hokey but I'm like it just told me
everything I needed to know pretty
instantly it was yep he got revved his
silly accent very quickly oh my god for
a little bit
just like no no go away I love you my
cookie but don't do a hexxit you like
the time hanging New York accent you
don't want to do it yeah I'm from New
York
you can't buy me I don't know what that
was that was a new knew what it was a
new what act but they mix it very
quickly very quickly it's almost like
after he like read four lines he's like
and dramas a spider-man boy let's be
honest uh it's very charming very
awkward Bavaria - yeah no Thomas this
more than the even the maguey like
honestly I'll say way more than Maguire
of him I thought Maguire was fine as a
high school spider-man
I use it particularly spider-man three
but I lose it the more they there he
said they supposed to age like that's
where I started to run into problems I'm
like him having trouble taking you
seriously so for me the jury is still
out on Holland because I'm like this is
only high school as I can he do adult
spider-man or even do it we were talking
about his voice and like oh my god if
he's like her number 20 or whatever
that's his voice oh my god we're always
gonna have this voice he's never getting
her off but then we're hearing like
that's a voice he's doing the sound
younger if it's an effect
I'm really hoping so there are moments
where I'm just like oh my god kid like
that voiceover oh my they make them they
make a joke where he sounds like a girl
in the movie and then I'm like he has
altar which is very funny and yeah I say
oh you're that girl knows fellas no no
no girl yeah it's fucking funny but I'm
just worried because I'm like um we were
supposed to get a spider a man in our
spider-man movie oh yeah so I'm I'm
Jerry still I'm hopeful I I'm just a
little worried because he looks so yeah
now he's playing 15 so I'm like this but
I'm like when it gets to words like
going that spider-man's out of college
are they gonna be able to pull that off
I'm just gonna no you still look 15 but
no his best hands down High School
Parker easily like and I like I had no
problem with Maguire as the high school
Parker I thought
appropriately nerdy he looked young
enough so I didn't have an issue the art
field was clearly in college when he was
in high school Garvey was an awful high
school Parker like there's no I laughed
my ass off I'm like really were starting
this in high school but I bought him
entirely as postgraduate like I'm like
okay that's an adult Parker he's a way
better it's called Parker than Maguire
ever was
so he's like Holland's really good the
cat for the most part the cast they
surround him with at the high school is
really good the high school was
realistic they changed it up so now it's
like this kind it looks like a magnet
school like some sort of super smart
like tech they they had some name was
like a tech school or something well
yeah science team a's on it everything
yeah and so it makes sense that he's
like this super brilliant kid and
whatever he that seems like he's got
more of the resources to create some of
this shit whereas him in the original
like i want to say even in the comic and
in the original ones it's like how did
this guy surrounded by dunces at some
public school just yeah you know like
get the resources to just make all this
shit and then this one I'm like notice
this adds up all the all of the
characters around them are characters
there's they're like very likable super
funny yeah I promise I believed the high
school a lot of these jokes if I've read
them in the script I wouldn't laugh but
then when you see them done it opens up
when you see him he's filming himself
like on his phone I'm thinking oh Christ
we're doing this we're good but it's
hilarious it is so funny and so many of
these jokes you think like okay well we
seen these before and we've seen this
kind of stuff there is something about
these characters and this timing and the
spacing and the editing is that it's
really charming it is really abusing it
he got Iron Man stuff was not as
intrusive as the ads would be Judy yeah
which I'm happy about
there's still some larger issues with it
I'll go into when we get into the
negatives but it those scenes actually
turned to the movie on for me like until
those scenes I'm just like this isn't
even a movie this is a series of
Spiderman hi Jo
dark into the picture all of a sudden
I'm just like oh now we're in a real
movie there's a very loose plot thread
about trying to find these weapons in
the vulture but it's really loose yeah
yes following Peter around and it's it's
very clear this movie is done to be kind
of a smaller movie Calla smaller high
school movie and it does not want to be
the big epic that the other spider-man
knows we're trying to be and that's I
think that's where it gets a little
tricky because it's it's fine for that
uh and we know why they're doing it
because they're trying to do something
different than all the experiment movies
have done it's so closely together so
everything like I totally get it and
it's fun and it's very enjoyable go have
a good time
uh I will see ya before we get to the
negative I will say this I I'm not
saying this is a bad movie no I know oh
it's like good I will tell you now go
see it I I can't guarantee you'll like
it but I have a hard time believing that
you're gonna come out of this do what
this is garbage like that we had like
Wonder yeah I wonder a little bit like
if you're just like no this is trash
like it's like people came out of 40 so
it's like garbage I'm like I don't think
you know what garbage is ya know I feel
like it's very hard to find someone who
can't go into this movie and see that
yes boy I still I energy laugh funny
they laughed my ass off it was well
worth the money I got my money's worth
I don't regret seeing it like so but the
by all means I am recommending you go
see it okay so that's that's our
recommendation go see it fi it's a lot
of fight it's not a huge epic movie it's
a smaller fun enjoyable flick definitely
enjoy it okay so this is point no no no
no we're done right like yeah okay this
is this is totally gonna be geek out you
if you love the movie and seeing two
people bring facts into this scares you
cuz yeah yeah it's a great half of a
spider yeah the second half like this is
fucking awesome
second hands cuter the most part is near
pitch perfect the first half I'm just
like I'm watching a series of like it
you know what it feels like it's like
those things they do online where it's
like see what Peter Parker is doing in
between the other spider-man movies
that's what the whole fucking know you
you actually nailed it when you said the
first half kind of feels like
Nickelodeon spider-man or Disney Channel
spider-man yeah but it's done well yeah
funny by this is what it feels like and
like take this with a grain of the lake
just don't kill me but I'm just gonna
say it is super fucking shallow it is
shallow now unlike Disney films are a
bunch in there like some of the Disney
Channel stuff for Nickelodeon stuff
which is what it reminds me of it's
executed flawlessly like the shallowness
is executed perfectly so you're having a
good time it's funny
there's no unlike the other spider-man
films how many cringe-worthy moments are
in this can you remember any the effects
a touch no no no but I mean I'm talking
about any yeah the only one I could
think of from any of this famine movies
where I'm like okay that was pretty sad
there was no cringe worthy in this was
the amazing spider-man all the other
spider-man movies have oh what that that
got by like you said that you showed
that Mary yeah as far as I remember
there was nothing in this that I'm like
I can't believe that got by a script
doctor or the Dreier or none of that
here so that's about yeah it's executed
flawlessly but it's it's shallow there
is none they're like the biggest problem
I had with this movie is the first half
in particular I'm like I have no idea
what is driving this kid why am i have
no i what his wife yeah and like do they
even say the words Uncle Ben no and like
I had this any songs were a lot that's
all we get and I didn't even put
together here's what I was saying it
feels to me like this whole movie is a
giant payoff like a reward for getting
through a movie like a great set of that
never had
mmm like it's like you know how you get
to there's like that kind of sequel
thing words it's like all right we we
set you up with the first one with
everything now let's just let's have fun
let's do what we want with this
character let's let's go for it
but we never had that yeah we never once
had that with this universe you can
argue Cody McGuire feeling the mark well
yeah it's good but we never had it with
this kid yeah and that is an issue and I
know everyone making this film is
assuming you have seen the other
spider-man movies because you probably
have but still going into this as a film
it is like yeah this kids like I got the
spider prize I just want to do stuff I
want to get fun yeah and oh it's a
little harder than I thought and it's
not only that it yeah it's rough it's
rough because what little and I mean
little character development barriers
for this spider-man all came in another
movie yeah anything that told you who
this kid was came in which one we would
frickin Civil War hmm yeah came in that
movie like I just cuz I was just like
maybe I'm nuts
maybe they told you everything you
needed to know about Peter Parker and
Civil War and I'm this so I'm watching
like they told you a few things it's
like well but it's all this cryptic kind
of like shit that would work fine in
that movie cuz like aha cuz they're
gonna tell us in the spider-man film
that's coming I'm still kind of holding
out in another spider-man movie that we
are gonna get an origin story and I'm
hoping they do become no because if they
do I think this would actually kind of
be brilliant that you have this feeling
just to kind of have fun and stuff and
then the next what kinda like an anime
in the next one you go into the origin
and the past and stuff like that you can
have more time to work it out because
like now cuz I dunno people are sick
that's you get bit by this but what is
armpit was about that's what that should
have been about you don't go like oh
well we're gonna give you the t's in
Civil War and I mean like now we're
going to give you a two-hour twelve hold
on no and then we're gonna finally tell
you what this guy is about you've seen a
ton of these animes where they drop you
off right in the middle
until episode six or seven that the end
on the mountain I true the arm we don't
get you get a pilot episode sometimes
it's a two-parter and then right away
you launch the best episodes
okay Full Metal Alchemist yeah that
don't see you in the the original FMA
dumped you in like somewhere in the
middle of the story to give you an idea
of here's this guy here are the powers
they have here's this mission they're on
here's what they can do two episodes
episode three starts right at the
beginning and gives you the origin story
[Music]
this is the problem I'm like okay so
that's what Civil War was about and I
had no problem with the way they didn't
have a glass of Laura's episode one
there's no episodes OVA episode three or
they get the Beckster and this was to
like this is a two-hour movie that you
blew and the thing is I don't even need
a full origin story that's not the issue
I don't need a whole the whole bit with
Uncle Ben from the very beginning in
this net but to make know like okay like
we were talking about this a kinetic on
I was talking to Carl's wife and she was
just like oh well like yeah but you
don't want to see the whole origin story
I'm like well I get that but you want to
like mention something I'm like whoa I
mean they mention Uncle Ben right I'm
like no her jaw just dropped and she's
like how can you not even mention it I'm
like search me like I I'm just and
that's the problem I have no and they
and people were like well you know
that's doing it spider-man well you know
I'm like do I do I really because here's
the problem I have they have changed
every single damn thing that you had and
I'm not complaining about the changes I
think most of the changes are fine but
when you change everything around the
character including the time that this
is supposed to start it it's enough and
where you go wait did what we think
happened happy because they never
mention Uncle Ben by I can't I'm not
sure they ever mentioned in my name in
Civil War or this they never mention he
got shot the closest we get is well
after everything aunt
went through so that's not enough okay
here's my connection am I supposed to
assume that he got shot that Peter feels
responsible for things like he kind of
hinted in civil war but I'm like was he
directly responsible wrong commander
what's uncle been killed in the event in
the Avengers fight with the aliens in
the sky portal in the Avengers freaking
clue here's an even let's say it did
let's say he did die any of those ways
let's say Uncle Ben is dead does he act
like he just lost an uncle does hope
he's doing this because he'll know and
if it happened pretty recently he got
over important you know for one of two
reasons are both either because it's
just the right thing to do what great
how good great responsibility or just
fun no that's what I would give that man
in the Civil War like watching that
scene again and savour I'm like they're
right there in that scene I could see I
lost somebody dear to me I want to get
it back this and that but they never
specifically said it so I'm like okay
well they're filling it in and it's okay
because that's Tony Stark's story and it
connects with Tony Stark's you know
being responsible for what's happening
in his plotline but now that we're in
this one it like literally I was talking
to some of the team four star guys and
they were suggesting and they're not
wrong he's like well there was a
character act the idea is he's tasted
power and the ability to save people
when he worked with the Avengers and he
wants to do it again he wants to get it
back and he keeps screwed up trying to
get it back I'm like okay that's fine
but that has nothing to do really with
like Uncle Ben or and then like there's
no connection back to like oh I
experienced this it runs behind a like
Batman won't be BAM in to impress his
girlfriend like if that's something else
like but we wasn't the parents kind of
them being motivator it's kind of one
thing you don't wanna be time so I
looked bad that's what it's like so I've
got this like I got this like in 1992 so
I was like 12 years old so I thought
well cuz I'm like he's like doing this
to impress the Avengers I'm like it just
seems kind of shallow to me and then I
felt well you know what the original
spider-man I'm like yeah tried to join
the Fantastic Four so I looked at bit up
again I'm like yeah it could be
jackass someone so let's read this again
cuz I had not read this in like 10 years
I look at it again and it's like right
there and print like oh yeah I have to
do this because Aunt May is gonna go
freakin broke because Uncle Ben is dead
and I have to do so that's why I want to
join the fantasy so it's worth their
like and that's the thing I don't need
everything I get what do you do bitch
just a few lines like something that
just indicates like that's what you need
to do is just reground us like
particularly when you changed everything
else reground us just tell us where we
are with this character and this movie
never tells you where you are with this
character and for as fun as it is and
it's I love the characters that I love
his I love how fun he is and everything
around it it just feels like a Disney
Channel high school yeah what Mike with
a house any idea of what's drive it does
not I'd argue it does so you kind of
where you are but it doesn't emotionally
make sense I had no emotional connection
you know even just hints and you're
supposed to read into it it's like this
does not connect to why spider-man does
what he does I only had an emotional
connection to him after like this is
where the spoiler was gonna start takes
the suit away when he went started
that's a weird thing it was like oh is
there too much dark and I'm like no
surprisingly when stark shows up that's
when the movie suddenly became that's
when it became a real movie he's kind of
the mentorians and it's like here's the
plot some cool Ben oh man July so you
know he comes in he's like well you
don't deserve the suit like you know
you're you're just you're running around
you're lying to me you're dead and all
of a sudden like and Peter is crushed by
this he goes back to Aunt May and is
crying to her and I'm like well this is
what I need like just some connection
like and I started to finally feel like
a connection like okay like this
character is actually going through
something where it was just an hour of
just him dicking around and it was like
it was entertaining don't get me wrong
I'm not saying oh I want my money back
I'm like I had a great time but I it was
nothing more than a superficial
connection like I'm watching a funny
comedy the best I intro to any of them
Louise was even to a necessarily super
good Marvel movie that was the
Incredible Hulk yeah he did is that they
show you everything about that this was
so brilliant they show you everything
about this character through little
flashes just a little flashback over the
credits about who this guy is what he
did what he became why he has to leave
he hurt his girlfriend who's after him
or her father this general and now he's
hiding out and brilliantly it actually
ties into the angling one so if you want
to see this as a sequel you can and I
feel like if they did something like
that with this fighter mate just be that
would have been not - that would have
been ins brilliant or like that one
fixed a long scene made me with Aunt May
just reach in like she's just like iris
under so much stress like I've got so
much shit going on and Uncle Ben is dead
and like just somethings I'm like okay
we're reconnecting like I know where we
are now I just I just did not get a grip
at any point uncle may's been through a
lot would you ever know a lot no nothing
but hot jokes about and that's and
that's another thing I'm not getting
like okay so it's really weird there's
there's a great scene and it's ruined by
the jokes about MA cuz I'm a guy you're
you're unusually hot and to the the guy
running the diner is like yeah she's hot
and then Peter like speak to him in
Italian or something and but so there's
this great scene where Peters like kind
of lies service as I lost the internship
with stark it starts like fuck it you
can't I'm taking the suit back she can't
even she okay so she like like he's like
sitting down and she walks up to him and
like her wait he's like her pelvis is
right here it jus like brings him in and
brings the head and and like yeah I
could only snicker like they've just
made her just this object of like yeah
she's hot then when that happens I'm
just like the turn of Rocky's nephew in
the world they turn it from a touching
scene to a touching see yeah and the
thing is like you can't be sincere about
it then I will give the Raimi spider-man
this is hokey as it is it was still
sincere and by yeah
cutting out like by trying to make it
sign I'd argue the first the Marquess
yeah first one is very sincere to this
this movie is strangely insincere at
points that it ruins the really truly
sincere points in other parts of the
film it does not feel even though he's
using Marvel problem you're right you
see fans celebrate time said this is a
Marvel issue it another great example
when my cookie when the vulture there's
the one guy that the fuck up guy whose
is like yeah you know what I'm out of
here I'm going at Michael Keynes like
yeah well you know what turns out I
can't let you leave and it's so rates
the fighter is right in front of
everybody and like I just like sat there
Mike I'm like dad to me these like he's
going evil like this is awesome
right after after that he says oh why
don't you see it a gravity gonna up like
you moves on but still yeah it was like
do something he became really
intimidating I'm like he was seriously
intimidating it was a moment of like
this guy's gone evil like he's he's gone
from like I'm just stealing to do this
like you know tell my family to like no
I just fucking kill the guy and it turns
out like will I didn't mean to do that
like it you could you do not cut off
Michael Keaton's balls like that you
just dump this is fuckin baman this guy
incinerated clowns with his Batmobile
well and they Suki Fair this leads us to
another huge spoiler which in our
opinion is where the movie gets really
good yeah oh shit are like not doing it
and they don't fully reveal why he's
doing it until the middle and so many
plot threads come together in this one
phenomenal reveal that we've seen so
many other movies but when it's revealed
here it's the audience just goes nuts
and they're all snickering and they're
uncomfortable there
it's just as great radiancy where he has
this crunchiness girls uh was a lily I
thing something like that I mean I want
to say Valerie but I think that really
is tooms is doing yeah they changed the
names which I thought what I'm like okay
like you you've played some shady shit
yeah they change the name some the cut
is going to take you to homecoming he's
not being spider-man skin used to being
you know that a high school kid okay
maybe I can do this goes knocked out
door there's the vulture there's Michael
Keaton everyone goes ball and the first
thing it goes in my head is oh my god he
got her he figured out who we yeah and
then it's like oh hey it must be Pete
come on in my daughter's waiting and
everyone audience just goes oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god cuz you oh no
no Larry the best thing about this when
we saw the screening at kinetic and and
the theater across from the conventions
are my favorite thing is during the
whole scene with Michael Keaton there
this is one guy in the way back there
god oh god
like during every single like cuz he's
like sharpening his knives like you're
doing this isn't the boy there's like
you know it's movies yeah he's just
perfect the girl honestly in this movie
is just the girl there is nothing to
this character at all and then and you
kind of realize like okay well that's
this early works out well actually
because way too are they going as a
Joanie another bait and switch which is
they're making her look like she's gonna
be Mary Jane she's not she's not she
without her pretty much for another
black Mary Jane
yeah which I thought it's a little funny
seeing you know how there's always
idiots that don't use it I will say like
I could I couldn't give two shits about
the race of that I'm sorry
fucking sick don't fucking care I will
say this though what does worry me a
little is I have zero problem of
changing the race of somebody I'm a
little worried when you do a wholesale
switch of personalities yeah like
character yeah this mary-jane they go
with is very Daria and in a weird way
I'm like I could see Gwen Stacy doing
that more than I could Mary Jane like
Mary Jane's nose always there yeah I
couldn't see either roomba Mary Jane was
always like the firebrand the actress
the drama queen that I'm just like hey
which again brings me back to my point
is when you don't ground us by telling
us like what is driving Peter Parker do
you change everything else like now Mary
Jane is Daria like what it's obvious
they're like yeah but but that's the
thing I'm like wait where are we here
it's like if Mary Jane is you know a
super cynical downer Daria
Michelle Jane how the hell we supposed
to put together what happened to Uncle
Ben and what is driving Peter Piper well
clearly this happened did it they don't
even say the guys they all chuckle Ben
come in in the next movie
honestly yeah oh my god out and this is
like spider-man's where the most
spider-man is like Batman of the or
Superman of the Marvel Universe it is
the flagship character the the funny
thing I was reading that book earlier
and like he who Stan Lee had the intro
and said it you know perfectly he's like
this is our Mickey Mouse this is our
mascot our flagship character this is
this is Marvel that is Spider Man then
he ended with excelsior yeah he actually
wrote that so and he's really really
complicated so you can't like just dumb
it down too
I just want to help people like no
there's more to to that and that was
literally the only thing I got out of
this movie and it's the only thing I got
I got hints in civil war but it's the
only thing I got out of war was like he
starts as a I get it you want to help
the little guy like that was it and I'm
like I'm not saying that that's not
noble but bullying that much he's kind
of lead by ever the most complicated
Marvel Universe's now just I just want
to help people and be a cool spider-man
like and I just know there's just more
to him than men and I said this on line
them people like how do you think that
these movies don't get it I'm like each
movie has like managed to just not get
something fundamental about the
character and that is this movie's
flawed that's what it doesn't get that
there's more to him than just oh I'm
just some dopey high school kid that
just wants to help people like if you
read the original comics he's under so
much pressure it's a great metaphor for
being a teenager it's like I got so much
shit on the horizon I got a deal with it
and that's just a little bit yeah yeah
that's there too a little bit cuz he
definitely juggling a lot of things and
it gets it gets to that point slowly
yeah there's some ground news not this
way if they are saying no no this didn't
happen a little bit they are not acting
like it's yeah I got act like that well
I know so so
Carl's wife was also saying like oh okay
yeah okay oh sorry we call my their
first names Oh what you're gonna have to
come back be she had another great but
oh no she said okay because they hadn't
seen it yet so I was telling him um no
go see it like it's really good but like
tone down your hype a little cuz like
maybe like that'll help you out a little
more like but she's like okay well so
but if you had never seen like most of
the other Avengers movies in the MCU
stuff like life and you know anything
about a minute here okay sure if you
were a casual fan only like could you go
into this and no and I'm like no you'd
be wondering like why does why is my
losses guy in the iron sued why is
spider-man like it did they try their
best with like this like photo recap
thing at the beginning where it was
before ever very it was clever and it
was awesome but it it still doesn't eat
hell you like macho deep in I do feel
like I think people just kind of it but
this way you have to know that this is
yeah but this is my problem I mean that
stuff is there you can go back this is
where the other spider-man stuff you
can't use movies this is my major
problem
Thor got his own movie
you know Captain America guys they all
have their own movies where you could go
okay I know who these people are and
then if you see movies with them in it
afterwards you still have you been bingo
okay I know what they are because I saw
that movie we don't have it here like if
you watch the Tobey Maguire film in the
marc webb film first up those two are
different alone yeah I should Tobey
Maguire and Andrew Garfield film the but
the Raimi in the Marc Webb those two are
already different and now you've changed
everything else from those two you don't
know where you are yeah and that's bad
bad bad storytelling I'm sorry I can't
get around like and it's a fun fun
comedy a great movie but when people
this is the perfect spider-man film I
know like it's time for the spider-man
film you have spider-man Vince I'm
concerned there's a soccer show yeah
there is no perfect spider-man no we and
and I don't think we're ever gonna get
one and that's what that's kind of what
bothers me about all of this is like and
people like you're being too hard on and
I'm like I'm not because I'm saying go
see and it's a great movie but I do
mourn the fact that I feel like this was
the last chance the last shot and now
we're done I'm just never gonna get like
a really truly great spider-man film
that gives me his origin gets what Peter
Parker's about the whole package each
one has a piece of the package and this
is probably like I would say my second
favorite I like Spider Raimi's
spider-man 2 a lot and this is my second
favorite and it's a this is probably my
second favorite fun it's a fun ass movie
like don't get me wrong but I'm like
we're done now I'm like this was the
last shot to just like be and like maybe
if I'm wrong and they do a great origin
story afterwards now well I bet
I'm holding out hope I'm just not sure
how I'm just not sure how you do it
because this was so far into it but but
it's it would be very very very hope I
hope I'm wrong but even if even if I'm
wrong and they do a great origin film I
still will argue that that was bad
storytelling that you don't sit here and
go oh we're gonna go a whole movie and a
half and then tell you this kids origin
and I realize there's so many things
like Sony botched it and now you just
gotta get it with Marvel but you there's
a lot of elements yeah yeah you could
have grounded it a little a few small
steps could have gone such a long way
and they didn't take it because they
wanted to go for jokes they wanted to do
the usual marble thing well let's make
it like a lion yeah
I totally get yeah because we but it's
not a demo and we handle tell me it's a
perfect spider-man movie I'm like no
yeah no with it maybe a little for a
decade we've had like three different
spider-man movies I can't even think of
a your movie series we've just had to
you know just these totally different
for movies our closes then yeah and they
only had to I mean we're on the three
now you know for this and so and I told
yet and those had so many botched scenes
and I'm Becca Julianne suppressants yes
spider-man was my favorite of all the
Marvel care like if you asked my
favorite superheroes I'm like spider-man
Batman like it was like for DC was
Bannen for Marvel it was spider-man so
it's just depressing that the greatest
in my opinion of all Marvel superheroes
has now been reduced to something that
is very very entertaining but all of the
complexity have removed yeah and that's
what happens to when you've got sick it
was like seven screenwriters and it
shows because what this feels like is a
very special episode sitcom hmm where
it's just like all the jokes are funny
and they land and they they hit a few
dramatic moments but it's it's still
just kind of shallow like most succumbs
are like it's very light
yeah it doesn't achieve anything more
you know it doesn't achieve necessarily
greatness above and beyond itself you
know is it is it weird when you think
about the fact that technically the
first guardians of the galaxy has more
of an emotional dimension t-bird I'm and
I woke up this morning and realize that
and
I was just like oh I'm like the movie
with the toy yeah and and that's the
problem like as fun as I had in
spider-man I'm like the movie with the
fucking talking raccoon and dancing tree
both of them the Frison the sequel I
connected more to those characters and
they ended yeah yeah
I I want to enter I connected to the
villain in this thang I connected to the
vulture but probably more than any of
the other villains in and it's not for
want of trying because I think the
acting in this Mumbai everybody is great
it's not slamming Tom Holland at all I
thought he was awesome
no and I you know one thing I'll see if
I marry MJ I'll say is that uh at least
in the movies uh I never got into the MJ
character I thought she was so boring
and so dull and just like is it the girl
she isn't that what Lilly gorilla was in
this this MJ at the very least I'm
watching this movie and I'm thinking
like you know part of he's really
wishing he just wasn't good after this
other girl and you go back to this
morbid weird girl cuz she's a lot more
interesting and now they're building up
that he is and I'm kind of like you know
that's 100% different and that's not
Mary Jane by any you know it's kind of
like I kind of interesting though I will
ask you this though from a storytelling
perspective what is the purpose like
Mary Jane is the romantic interest its I
have a Mary Jane our Gwen Stacy what is
the purpose of doing a bait-and-switch
with throwing somebody else in there
making you things she's gonna be married
like it's not and this is part of the
novel of this I think it's nothing more
than a twist like and it's not bad but
it was fun for just a twist now I'll
give it a hint more and again this is
not necessarily good storytelling it's
setting of all the other problems that
have been set up by the other films and
Sony and stuff is that if you told us at
the very beginning that was MJ everyone
Jessie don't know just immediately and I
think by having her be funny be cynical
be kind of weird and sort of build it up
by the end I'm sure those people are
gonna still gonna be like no and I
understand that it's not the character
but it's still like okay like some
people like I warmed up to that like
okay I would like to Samantha Sam
commentary on society talk about the
character I'm not talking about Richard
I'll talk about the character is so cuz
that is in almost no way
mary-jane the way she acts everything is
not Mary Jane this is my problem is why
can't you just do Mary liked it
spend my promo long why can't you just
do it fucking right then like whoom now
we have to change everything because
this seems just in and maybe this is
maybe all credit to Lee and Ditko on
this like it maybe just it's impossible
to do like they wrote such a great
character and a great way no and here's
the baby this is just hubris like trying
to adapt the last airbender and this is
what I didn't know see cuz like you grew
up you were more spider miles more x-men
we both love Batman but the one thing
that you were saying is that you said
Mary Jane when you described her later
you said no she's like a Spitfire she
has a lot of energy she's that come on
let's go I don't worry about that she's
just you know I'll do what every image
of her the earlier now mix she's always
like she's got like this big smile and
that was something when you said that
I'm like oh that's what they were trying
to do in the Sam Raimi spider-man but
that's not all we came across and event
and I know she has like a tragic
backstory and like you know what they
were doing in the Raimi spider-man was
great with her background but I'm just
like still if I just but she's still
just bell girl she's spider-man one it
ends with her being dangled by the Green
Goblin spider-man two it ends with her
being dangled by octopus spider-man
three and lay ya know the only revenue
Gwen Stacy on the other hand who was my
favorite in the comics they nailed but I
like to go in Stacy in the first one
when she's like fucking MacGyver trying
to build like a hairspray but that's one
of the things where I was saying is that
with uh you know I didn't know she was
supposed to be like that
so that is something it's like you know
I think but that is tricky to do I don't
feel you have to fight this is a bit
Riley get a really good actress but I'm
like there's no smearing yeah they're
not Mary Jane at all no no not at all
that's my other to me more than ever
than any racial element I don't know but
my exes better know but people are all
truly is for all I care but if you
completely change your personality and
there's people they're upset that at me
is a lot younger and pretty much a
totally different character uh but I can
also look at her be like that's funny
that's different and I've seen it before
it seemed thing I want
I don't want this thing it's like I
could see both sides I don't have
problems with changes as much like I
would probably have less problems with
any of this if there was some grounding
going on if you could like take us
through steps to like okay this is the
universe but as we've noted they just
they just don't and then the like it's
weird the way they fix some problems
like putting in the tech school is
interesting but there's still other
problems like now it's all geeks picking
on each other yeah it's all weird
which then now the funny thing is like
it's ironic but it also makes me laugh
because this is what the internet is all
about how many times they're watching
dirty-ass fanboys what the hell are we
doing picking on other people overlay
lated like the geeks have now completely
become the bullies in many cases the
Kings have inherit the derp but this is
this is my problem is that for switching
all that around which I thought well
this is actually kind of clever I was
talking to the team four star guys about
this because I thought that they had a
good point and Andre Andre Meadows the
black nerd said he loved that aspect he
was like geeks will do that they will
turn on each other like and I'm like
yeah so that wasn't the problem the
weird thing is for all of the changes
they made to then they make the same
mistake even worse though I think that
in some of the earlier spider-man films
of their stupid portrayals of high
school witches okay flash
why is he popular he's the jock he's
muscular he's not like in this one I
smart I guess we don't that exact she's
not that smart okay so here's the thing
I have no / on every single night
flash and every single level is a fuckup
he's unlikable
he's unlovable is it like that's the
thing about flash in the the Ramey
spread room all right he's a child like
the giggles in the other guys is
admiring him for his money his physical
basically prowess this guy has nothing
like I was like trying to pick up like
what is his deal I'm like well maybe
he's super smart not super smart he's an
idiot he drags rest of the team down at
the time well maybe he's really funny
he's not that funny he has like a crack
or two against Peter but it's not very
good his Bell penis Parker that's darker
I'm like maybe I'm like this guy has no
redeeming quality and that is like none
else but he's the way yeah until they
mentioned it splash I'm like why is
anybody like there has to be a reason
like there is something like people have
certain charisma like they have charisma
at least he has zero charisma I'm like
what is this guy's feel like it's the
same mistake he's just a bully for
bully's sake like there is nothing it's
to me it's a little bit worse than some
of the other ones cuz at least it was
like alright well flash is ripped as
fuck and like yeah it's like this guy is
the nemesis and it's almost like
overthinking it too ironically make it
more simple jumble in there I just feel
like like maybe if there was a pecking
order and flash is second to Peters last
I didn't get that either I got that
flash it's still somewhere up top
somewhere and I'm like what I don't know
it was just weird
like it's just little things like that
like so yeah I'm trying to fit I think
that's about the only thing I'll say and
the client the climate yeah yeah no no
no see a lot of the action is clunky
uh-uh but the plane battle in particular
like kind of disappointing a lot of the
CG is not very good the ending
particular is you can't make out what's
going on there on the plane that cloaks
itself so there's that then parts of the
plane start fidgeting so sometimes
flashing away folks it's kind of cool I
like that you can do yeah I don't and
thence parts of it start fidgeting there
messing around things so it starts
flashing white parts of it there sparks
flying and it's in the dark how are you
gonna see any of and the vulture is
black - like a covered in black yeah and
the only thing I like about the vultures
those green eyes are intimidated like
yeah I like the design but yeah it's
like and it's done in like this kind of
shaky cam and it like honestly it's
fucking cheesy I said I mean it was
cheesy as all hell like I liked the
finale - Wonder Woman better cuz of like
well I can see what's going on ya know
and then he just like and then the
ending where he's just like no don't
take off like it'll kill you I'm trying
to say whatever but where's the rest of
the bit of thank Christ they didn't kill
him though cuz my god I'm so excited I
can't wait okay here's the other thing
we both got really pissed off at this
cuz okay superhero movies are everywhere
and there's great action great
characters and stuff like that all these
great scenarios we have always want to
see an action scene with seven
appearance menus mid-part sure enough
this plane is flying over to music
parties on the island
yeah the vulture could pick up innocent
civilians and thread the coast or what's
going over the hills with vultures
flying around set the possibilities
they're just on the fucking beach hey
stop them from flying they don't even
touch that goddamn amusement park it's
like fuck you you got the empties and
then he sits on the cyclone at the end
just like yeah I guess I'm sad I would
have been cool to have a fight on this
roller coaster when is the superhero
movie gonna do his fighting it would
have been perfect he can stick to stick
on the roller coaster
no no it's go with a flying villain yeah
budget cuts it's like well Sony still
owns half of this we're not gonna go off
take out the amusement park you don't
tease us cuz Marvel even DC I don't care
somebody get on that get a climax the
attend amusement park on a roller
coaster come on it's like the amazing
Ned is in this I don't know if they're
gonna go full Hobgoblin him or not a
frame like dude the storyline from that
but who one of Parker's like best
friends it's it's kind of so long they
worry they have a nice I'm wondering
what they like cuz Ned the ends up
becoming a reporter too I think like if
they have a nice family to ultimate
spider-man in there I thought was clever
that is like yeah who's that - yeah yeah
we did at first I was thinking like
we'll wait but then maybe - just
marketing-wise if he could fade there's
two spider-man's in a movie versus
afiyah but don't thinking like if you do
another spider-man movie comes across
him get the backstory and then there's
just kind of - running around working
together and then he goes off his other
movie called ultimate spy amazing yeah
that could totally work you could do
that although I hear they're kind of
combining the two stories here - like
the best friend I guess is kind of like
Miles Morales best friend but I don't
know what ton about it I had to be told
I have to worry so you know this is
connection to my own Morales I'm just
like okay like your own says that's a
really good fighter man
so okay after saying all that it's still
fun it's not enjoyable it's just the
perfect spider-man movie that everybody
yeah it's sitting at night got the cool
gears it's got the cool get don't say
this suit is amazing
before you go the eyes yeah I mean that
you edits so much more character when
you spider-man have those eyes changed
yeah and that's sitting at 93% of Rotten
Tomatoes and if you know how Rotten
Tomatoes works and a lot of people don't
[Music]
they could say I gave it three stars if
you get a stars you get a lot of the
reviews I'm reading are in the 3-star
category and that's what I'm like this
three out of four stars yeah that's what
I was a very entertaining three-star
movie so it go see it it's just it's not
the perfect spider-man at this point I'm
not sure we're ever gonna get the
perfect spider-man I'm just that one
aspect of it depresses me yeah it is the
best high school Parker I've seen so it
nailed that right and I think a lot of
people got so burnt out on the other two
that they're giving this one major pain
yes her yzma and the fact that it's fun
counts for a lot
I think people are giving it major
passes because they because this is the
best high school Parker we've seen them
they're like it's the perfect spider I'm
like no it's half a Spider Man but the
things that it got right are done so
good I think you're just like like I
understand we've been burned quite a few
times blame I can't blame people with
that but if you're gonna like throw
rocks at me and be like how dare you say
this is just like it's not like it isn't
there yeah yeah we examine the movie or
not yeah and look at it is remember this
is Marvel's greatest superhero don't you
think maybe we should mention uncle like
you know like something like yeah but no
but it is fun we liked it
I'm sure in your life or how does that
we brought up but it's all there you
know we'd still like to find more it
pisses me off more with this film even
than some of the others because it got
so much right yeah in a really very jar
the whole package now it's like you've
really given us a taste of what could
have been and it's like but still I'm
with you I think this is probably my
second favorite by Malecha me yeah Iron
Man the most you'll experiment to the
most very different but I mean they're
probably below that Raimi's spider-man
after that man-to-man free ride oh man -
yeah amazing spider-man 2 and then
spider-man 3
yeah yeah that's tough honestly I
probably like amazing spider-man 2 just
because the chemistry there's no charm
those who was so good whereas spider-man
3 was such a dumpster fire on every
level yeah like I can't think of one
redeeming thing about spider-man 3
outside of Sandman
there's there's a lot of things that do
like it's pie-der-man free but yeah yeah
yeah a MS claim doing great I've never
forgiven you - no no I did not say
what's the Kerman I said out of all
these movies that have some of the
coolest scenes I've ever seen I like
that spider-man 3 when I think of the
biggest cinematic disappointments of my
life that ranks somewhere in the top 5
because I was so psyched after
spider-man to like we've got him to a
point where maturing him as an adult the
third one this is gonna be it like this
is gonna be great
like because spider-man dude was so good
that I'm just like this is one of the
most disappointing things I just six
life because the other two I'm like okay
I guess this is just what we're doing so
by the time - ended I'm like okay I'll
just accept whatever goofy crazy
whatever and maybe you know maybe that's
it I set the bar so low that when I saw
spider-man 3 had had some of those cool
scenes I'm like okay that's and you said
it really high don't when you saw the
really really bad scenes and like just
brought you down so well I I have no
doubt that that's what's going on here
with so me I think a lot of people set
the bar really low because of what we've
had so far and I get with week I said we
were not just like I said it directly in
the middle of just like yeah this could
go either way and I sat there and I
first have for the film I'm like I am
having such a good time but I just sat
there I'm like there was something in my
head I'm like something's not right
like I'm not that I'm not clicking here
I'm like I'm laughing I'm a man because
I was we were all laughing like yeah the
theater was just but I'm like there's
just something off and I spent like
hours afterwards just with whatever a
little free time we have like just
whatever a little free time we had hours
I didn't even post about it - but I
spent hours thing about over the next
two days because I kept waking up every
morning thinking my thought was gonna
change like no no it's actually it's
right close to the perfect I thought it
was like the more I thought about that
the more I'm just like no actually gets
a little like worse and worse not like
it's a bad movie way but I'm like it's
not it's kind of like that climax to a
Wonder Woman gets worse and worse the
more I think about like I wonder what
like they have a climax just gets dumber
and dumber
support them heart I I am hopeful
nothing would make me happier than if
they do another one and they nail I
think think it's motivation oh sure they
can know just like they could have done
it right this dunno but I think they can
do it and it can kind of redeem this one
and the problems of this one stuff I'm
not saying they will die I think they
can I think it'd be tricky but I think
it could be I want that to happen I'm
not saying it can't be done I have no
hope I'm going in there with zero
expectations
apart from well because Marvel may have
an out will be entertaining at least but
yeah it's the this sort of insincerity
there's a great video out there that
makes some legit points I argue the
examples they pick her kind of wrong but
there's a video to talk about like why
Wonder Woman works where some of the
Marvel films don't and he uses the
earlier spider-man films as example
about how when Parker gets his powers he
has these moments of like wow this is
amazing and it's in its kind of epic and
we were robbed of that in this film but
at the same time he uses like he says a
problem of marbles that they take there
was some technical term for it I'm
forgetting right now because we've been
talking for an hour but they take
moments that are sincere and should be
serious and turned them into a joke
exactly like what happened with vulture
that should have been the serious moment
where he kills that guy and then it's
like alright never easy anti-gravity god
no that should have been when we're
going holy shit
and he used the example used that was
bullshit I'm like I wish he picked a
better cuz he went with Doctor Strange
is when Doctor Strange puts the the
cloaca on the cape or whatever that's
like dump dump done and then the Cape
like touches quit it quit it is like
there that's example I'm like but that's
the wrong movie the pic cuz the whole
point of Doctor Strange was this was an
arrogant narcissistic son of a bitch who
had to be taken down multiple pegs to
get to a point yeah so that that
actually worked so well in that movie
it's such a bad example to use but this
movie I think has a number of good
examples where like that kind of happy
instead we went be yeah this is missing
the sincerity in a number of moments
that the Raimi film had but the Raimi
film was so hokey another moment
the Brandis film's climax was garbage
where they did the mary jane gwen stacy
switch up like you know like they put
her on the bridge instead with a goblin
and so it's like each one gets a piece
and this one got a lot of the pieces
right and does it so well yeah neither
of us think this is the perfect
spider-man that a lot of people are
saying it just I'll say it's just it's a
step in the right direction but yeah I
hope they listen and take it to heart
like give us something to latch on to
with this character this is Peter
fucking Parker this is Marvel's greatest
state if you were to eat more than just
running around high school at the
fucking homecoming dance no I you know
you were saying that Stanley was saying
that spider-man is like their Mickey
Mouse and you know I like x-men I like
you know these other ones and stuff I
like spider-man fine I see what he's
Mickey Mouse it's a complex interesting
phenomenal character has all these great
powers what's great back story answer if
you were to show me this movie you'd be
like yeah now that you see what
spider-man is amazing right I'd be like
no hey yeah I'm like what that's a cute
like that's adorable
yeah I would not be like why is this
guy's the greatest I wouldn't be like
haha yes like you show me Batman to be
like then DC's most meaty complex
Caravan be like yes I get it you know
they're Cola it's bright look of that
battle it's it's right here let me let
me just read this to you and the Lemus
silent figure slowly fades into the
gathering darkness aware at last that in
this world with great power there must
also come great responsibility and so a
legend is born and the new name is added
to the roster of those who make the
world of fantasy the most exciting realm
of all things I did not get out of this
movie as entertaining as it was ever
good right right there right right where
I can't there's there's your back yeah
yeah right right right right there yeah
look at that image yeah look at that
image like and that's that's what's
missing that's where I know still
doesn't get it
oh holy Christ
really good writing that's what and
that's what rainy - and rainy didn't
succeed always and that the film has a
lot of problems and by its we embrace
understand God that's what we got in
this film does it employee-id are you
even the first Marc Webb tried to get it
and then many ways got it and yeah and
this is mine now Tony Stark talking in a
porch through the suit light and I'm
like that does not have the same
resonance as that no and there's silly
moments don't get us wrong but I mean
this is the first of the new spider-man
movies and that is definitely not it but
it is fun as an entertaining film it is
great you'll get your money funny
entertaining charming delightful as a
representation of this is the movie that
represents the greatest superhero of all
time and it's perfect but it's fun this
is what happens when you talk about
cultural icons yeah okay and that's why
we're we're harping on this cuz this is
something this is the hugest thing in
Marvel ever yeah so don't take this like
we're saying the movie sucks but it's
it's very hard you have to weigh
everything and it like it's it's a lot
of fun go see it enjoy your money just I
don't think it's perfect yeah no I agree
III still recommend it it's loads of fun
yeah it's definitely not the perfect
spider-man or opinion but yeah so there
it is hope you guys have fun for happily
I have no idea how long I'm probably I
hope you have fun stoning us today yes
coming but would be the first time you
and me the first time buzzer - cool
we'll see you next time bye that was
cathartic I feel good still see it but
you